[Music]
this batch you of Liberty gag does
nothing to keep me from getting
frustrated at another 40 seconds of
logos are these suddenly lit candles on
some sort of motion timer or do they
just have a setting for when the joke
demands oh hush little bad pirate don't
say a word
I'm 87% sure the pitch for this movie
was Adam Sandler will sing in a weird
Dracula voice immediately followed by a
400 studio execs putting down payments
on in-ground pools and new breasts I've
odd you want to kiss her tush
considering you're about to change a
dirty diaper right now I'm all sorts of
read it out exactly how vampires
interact with their children this movie
finally answers the question that no one
was asking do vampires oh we never go
out there ever
then maybe keep the door shut does
Dracula have the ability to travel into
the future because in order to have a
children's book like that in 1895 you
would have to do two
let me wipe all your poopy way Sam there
lands his second poop joke in the first
three minutes of the movie can he keep
this incredible fecal ratio going for
the rest of the film there's still a lot
of movie left so let's make like
Shawshank and see how much we have left
to crawl through really finally get the
freedom you thought I was kidding about
the pitch but less than three minutes in
we've already had two Sandler songs you
moving well didn't rhyme at all
zom Jekyll implication but of course be
smart
no bonfires no firework shows fire
shadowing yeah it's a mess back there
where exactly is this Pumpkinhead
editing spending the cash Wain just gave
it welcome to Hotel Transylvania
Roland edits I have personally designed
the spectacular schedule of events all
leading my daughter's birthday
extravaganza tomorrow
so you're just forcing the guests to
participate in your daughter's birthday
celebration Dracula might be losing some
of these vacationers to sandals next
year there is a clogged toilet 340i so
many poop jokes you know what let's just
send them all right now so we don't to
worry about this anymore
[Music]
a sentient sponge that gets off an
absorbing urine we aren't even ten
minutes into this thing and I swear I'm
already losing my will to breathe any
more oxygen from this planet
all right everyone say it together now
Frankenstein was a scientist not the
monster we all good now can we move on
so Frank's pieces are just connected by
flat surfaces no wonder he falls apart
so much monster stink you're kidding me
right in my lobby
Dracula didn't seem to concern when
Wayans kids were pissing all over the
furniture but this is where he draws the
line only Martha were here to see this
she's always here one in your left
breast pocket get it it's a toadstool
nice visual pun and all but it has
nothing to do with this movie and
doesn't even adhere to anything
resembling the laws of EM physics you're
old enough to drive a hearse now you're
old enough to make your own choices you
have to be a hundred and eighteen to
drive on your own that's a lot of years
of having to drop Mavis off at scare
camp wait why did this shirt shrink when
she turned into a bat but the Hat didn't
guys guys she can handle it she's a
Dracula for pete's sake but seriously
watch out for fire he says in a room
with about a hundred lit candles also in
118 years Mavis has never thought to
sneak out don't you bring ET into this
Mavis don't you dare damn it it's 1:00
now my baby will be safe forever so a
father demonizes the outside world by
creating fake creatures to keep his kids
in a secluded community forever no one
told me this was actually a remake of
the village hey you don't need a
mannequin leave the mannequin here well
now we know where Andrew McCarthy has
been all these years
why is the revolving door still spinning
wouldn't it be hitting them continuously
you have to leave Oh No
Dracula could easily just burn right
past these monsters but instead needs to
make the situation more difficult than
it needs to be because Sandler can't
resist a resolution better suited for a
sitcom than a motion picture can't kill
him
it would set monsters back hundreds of
years considering no one else knows the
monsters or hotel is here seems like a
non-issue right now Quasimodo
why is Quasimodo here isn't he
technically just a human with physical
deformities in fact I'm pretty sure the
whole point of the story was that he was
not a monster
even though everyone treated him like
one drunk Dewey how did Jonathan manage
to Monster Mash this flying brain we've
only seen them flying above the floor
what was it even doing down there
where did the shrunken head on the
doorknob come from it wasn't there when
Dracula and Jonathan initially entered
the room is that real about the garlic
thing yes I cannot have my throat swells
if Drac really sees humans as the enemy
why is he being so upfront with this one
his weaknesses come on man loose lips
sink overacted infantile animated Adam
Sandler movies at least I think that's
how that quote goes yes I know
I apologize go go back to doing what you
were doing in sex wrong with you people
seriously you have a secret door that
opens into the honeymoon suite and
another that opens into the shower are
we sure Drac didn't build this hotel
because he's a giant vamper Burt also a
bare-bones humor hey what are you doing
here no Mavis what are you doing here is
one of your vampire powers plot
advancement these monsters gonna kill me
not as long as they think you're a
monster huh that's kinda racist
Johnny Stein would be excellent at
cinemasins what brings you here Oh party
planner I get that these monsters
haven't been around a lot of humans if
any but they've been around monsters
enough that they should know Jonathan is
not one even though the whole thing with
Johnny is a ruse Mavis his surprise
party isn't so why is she there watching
a potential band that could be playing
for her later
did you just reference Mavis now being
legal and everyone's cool with this in
monsters also awful band somehow knows
new song when a stranger hops up and
starts a cliche and 20 there's no end 27
and bingo the end column has numbers 31
through 45 I call bingo shenanigans
shenanigans not sure how Bride of
Frankenstein here has five different
bingo cards that are identical and
furthermore how they all have different
numbers stamped on them why do these
flies eyes have pupils one earlier they
had more accurate compound eyes also
since when is charades a spectator sport
are there professional charades
tournaments I'm unaware of if I wanted
to just sit and watch someone flail
their arms around like crazy for no
reason I'd watch a youtube vlogger this
movie has an actual scooter montage the
monsters are taking turns riding a
scooter to the tune of sexy and I know
it it's literally the only instance of
LMFAO that happens in this entire movie
relax no one suspects anything the only
thing that looks weird how much
whispering you're doing except this has
happened quite a few times and no one
has noticed until now Oh dad that was
not fun
everyone running jumping swimming with
no order that was the opposite of fun so
it was the ridiculous six of parties
look
remember nothing of this encounter
you've had mind control powers and not
use them this whole time the whole time
follow me
oh no no Mavis I can't I have to leave
you sure it'll be fun okay the power of
boners compels you someone help me
understand the geography on this if he
came out of a chimney already how was he
not already seen this view I'm only
gonna be 121 once right gotta live it
yes but since vampires can't really die
very easily I'm guessing they haven't
steeped themselves in the deep
philosophies of the Yolo oh man
the sunrise from here must be amazed if
I know my astronomy and I'm sure I don't
the Sun actually starts by lighting the
highest point of the object and works
its way down as it rises seriously go
watch the Sun rise from your roof I'll
wait pick a joke movie does the sana
create steam from these coals or is it
the dragon you showed me earlier
neither joke is that funny anyhow so why
contradict yourself 17 to 40 a 16th of
47:19 would it make more sense to have
each table go to the spot nearest to
them since they're all the same
also is the tablecloth or the table the
ghost and how exactly does that work
neither of those items are alive in the
first place and therefore can never die
and come back as a ghost
so these monsters do still kill humans
pickle a movie right and all these extra
tables come from those tables be
breeding like rabbits
sir breaks Alon is what you're going
with really sure cuz the knights of the
round table joke was right there do you
love it occasionally MODOK yes wait so
these Knights of the Living Dead or some
sort of Alexa mesh network thing and
Quasimodo just happens to be walking
through a hallway with several of them
yeah that's certainly convenient why
does that hurt me because in an Adam
Sandler movie getting kicked in the nuts
is one of the greatest honors that can
be bestowed upon you the only way to
rank higher is if you go full Sandler
and take genital trauma while farting
loudly telling a poop joke and being
embarrassingly naked at the same time
and if I had a bridge I would jump
I'm sorry the last thing I wanted was to
hurt her or you because I met all of you
a few hours ago English please your
voice is really annoying see that's
funny because it's friend Drescher
saying it
Jesus this movie
the water in the pool didn't do anything
- Jonathan's hair her makeup but somehow
as Morelle de jumping on him does the
trick he says be holds a human why the
23-19 panic though sure they're finding
out he's human but they've been
literally partying with him all night
they know he isn't dangerous right but
the monsters brought luggage in items
right and where are they going to walk
to two lonely bags crashed in the night
they're eating first you tell us humans
are back now they're good but who on
dying and made Drac King any of these
monsters think for themselves don't they
I'll have homes where they might come
into contact with humans and make up
their own minds
okay ready Jonathan get the car he was
mountain climbing before he ended up at
the hotel if he had a car he would have
just gone back to it and never even seen
the hotel right so everyone is just
fully on board with monsters being real
in this universe and why would these
humans be carrying a torch so hardcore
for Frank if monsters not actually do
any monstering in this universe and if
not how do they even know what the hell
they are synchronize cape lifting
commercial airplanes retract the landing
gear immediately after takeoff unless of
course you install the ones with a sense
of slapstick comedic timing Acula what
my hands in a tan shoe so considering
track has been flying and direct
sunlight for the last three minutes and
now he's carrying on this completely
nonchalant and nonsense of a
conversation in full sunlight either
that whole vampires and the Sun thing is
just a minor inconvenience or movie has
too much moving to do to be bothered
with rule consistency oh sure
earlier when you needed mind control
Johnny a couple of millimeters thick
contacts prevented it but here you mind
zap through about an inch of heavy-duty
airplane glass it's almost like the
movie is trying to contradict itself I
hope you can hear me and forgive but
even if you can Jonathan is already on
the plane so maybe this is going to have
to give him a minute how is Dracula
still speaking through the pilot if he's
not in front of him to give him the
hypnotism eyes do you really mean it dad
go make your own parrot
but maybe somewhere with less Sun I
thought I found a love when she was just
a fling when did we decide all animated
movies had to end with a musical number
is it a way to trick the audience into
thinking they had more fun than they
really did as they leave as if a full
two minutes of assorted auto-tune
monsters forcibly rhyming the word zing
is going to cure somehow the 90 minutes
of nothingness that came before it the
Beastie Boys
my paint you feel of duty my mom bought
you when I was just 13 the brightest red
sweatshirt that oh we never go out there
do not go in there welcome to Fright
Night
for real when there was no crowd and he
found we hate saying yeah what we ate
saying come on fellas you you know that
I haven't sung in public since Martha
that's a big oh and if I see